[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
statut de loisirs toutes vos idées
sorties culturelles ou le dit que dans
le département
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 10 novembre
avis aux gourmands et aux curieux le
salon des vins des saveurs et des
couleurs de maurepas revient pour une
cinquième édition ce week end création
artisanat ou gastronomie il y en aura
pour tous les goûts
jenny clos ways présidente du lion's
club de maurepas goodwin qui organise
cet événement nous en parlera plus en
détail
roméo et juliette le classique de
shakespeare composé par prokofiev
revisité par le chorégraphe angelin
prejlocaj un drame au coeur des régimes
totalitaires ce chef d'oeuvre de latence
contemporaine et à redécouvrir à 50
enfants nous donc 27 ans après sa
création
et en parlant d'amour impossible pour
les plus jeunes cette fois flonflons et
musette deux amis séparés par la guerre
un spectacle drôle et émouvant jouer à
guyancourt ce week end mélanie est allé
le voir elle nous le présentera les
jeudis musicaux du centre de musique
baroque de versailles reviennent pour
une nouvelle saison chaque jeudi
jusqu'en juin les pages et les chantres
interprète des oeuvres des xviie et
xviiie siècles dans la chapelle royale
du château de versailles
l'entrée est libre prochain rendez vous
le 16 novembre avec des suites
instrumental extraites de psyché et des
amendes magnifique de jean baptiste
lully quand le blues américain rencontre
la culture touareg tinariwen mêle
habilement guitare électrique et
raillent ses chants folkloriques
traditionnelles de la musique algérienne
un cocktail à découvrir sur scène au
prisme d'elancourt le 24 novembre tv
60,18 vous fait gagner des places vous
pouvez tenter de remporter votre
invitation pour deux personnes sur notre
site
tv soixante dix huit points comme et je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait de ce
qui vous attend un titre issu de leur
dernier album et luan feeling et les
s'installe à bord mais que des faux 2010
way l'état zine eddine et de chaque fois
l'hymne à la nuit
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus d'un mois avant noël les
certains réfléchissent déjà aux cadeaux
ce week-end le lion's club de maurepas
vous propose de faire le plein d'idées
originales pour vous ou pour vos proches
il organise pour la 5ème année son salon
des vins et des saveurs et des couleurs
de quoi régaler les yeux comme les
papilles génique l'ouest président du
lion's club de maurepas est avec nous
bonjour et andy clowe est excusez moi je
suis encore tromper donc bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors vous pouvez nous
présenter ce salon qu'est ce qu'on
entend par sa veuve a on connaît mais
qu'est ce qu'on entend par saveurs et
par couleur alors les vins bien sûr ses
classiques et les saveurs de quoi
régaler toutes les papilles et les
couleurs c'est comme le fait le lions
club international la mise en valeur des
artistes avec des artistes locaux et
fabrique hors de doute tout toute chose
tout matériel artisanale qui qui peut
être l'objet de cadeaux de noël tout à
fait originaux donc dans les produits
phares évidemment il ya le vin le
fromage mais il ya aussi quelques
originalités notamment vous l'avais dit
au niveau de nos producteurs locaux
on pourra découvrir un expert des
escargots y tout à fait les escargots de
monsieur de vaud qui se situe dans à
côté de menthe donc qui viennent nous
rejoindre cette année donc nous allons
pouvoir les découvrir
et puis nous avons aussi
dans la région de menthe la pisciculture
de la ville est donc monsieur coupin
donc avec qui existe depuis 1917 aussi
donc ça sent en effet tout à fait donc
des fûts maison de deux truites et
dérivés donc voilà les chocolats aussi
l'artisanat du chocolat aussi on a un
chocolatier qui la boîte à chocolat
qu'il y a de ce raccourci qui est dans
les yvelines voilà et puis bien les
couleurs alors de quoi régaler toute
l'ailé le sexe féminin les femmes pour
tous et tous ses cadeaux de noël voilà
c'est l'occasion aussi de goûter à
d'autres cuisines car vous allez
accueillir des exposants venus de
partout le pays basque que la corse et
même madagascar oui mis à l'honneur
oui oui l'association aeve hamada qui
est une association d'agir qui participe
depuis cinq ans à notre salon qui
représente tous les produits de
madagascar aussi et qui elle aussi est
une association qui agit aussi pour pour
l'île de madagascar
de quoi découvrir de belles choses oui
tout à fait et vous l'avez évoqué
également pour les femmes alors là il ya
plutôt des bijoux des créations voilà et
notamment des vêtements
agnès leblond winnie créatrice deuxième
ligne d'elancourt sa focale veine pardon
oui de ben qui est une qui crée des
bijoux de perles de verre et et filles
nés de toutes les couleurs avec des
dégradés magnifique
il faut venir voir cesser c'est
rayonnant
voilà c'est vraiment à découvrir et
l'idée avec cet événement c'est donc de
faire découvrir la richesse de
l'artisanat on a parlé mais c'est aussi
et surtout de récolter des fonds
oui c'est ça le lions club international
fait des manifestations chaque chaque
euro gagné est un euro reversé pour nous
offre sociale et nous avons deux gros
projets set sur deux ans notamment un
grand projet sur deux ans qui est
d'offrir un chien guide
une personne malvoyante et on va le
réaliser en 2018
donc c'est un coup de 20000 euros nos
peu c'est pour ça qu'on a fait ce projet
sur deux ans et puis cette année aussi
nous avons dédié un stand à
l'association valentin haüy qui est une
association dont ceux qui aident
nationale qui aide les les aveugles et
les malvoyants
donc on lance alors offert un stand et
donc ils vont être là pendant les deux
jours et ils vont organiser des jeux de
dégustations à l aveugle avec tous les
chalands les exposants donc ça va être
très convivial et très chaleureux pour
aller faire un petit mot sur les
modalités dans les infos pratiques alors
quand et où aura lieu ce salon des vins
et oui alors c'est samedi 11 et dimanche
12 novembre donc ce week-end les portes
sont ouvertes et l'entrée libre de 10
heures à 20 heures le samedi et de 10h à
18h les dimanches à ne pas manquer donc
là les américaines
et si vous êtes en panne d'inspiration
pour noël donc fait le plein d'idées
cadeaux dans ce salon
merci beaucoup en tout cas jany que
chloride est revenu sur notre plateau et
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site internet du vaillance clave
également merci beaucoup j'aime merci à
vous c'est une histoire d'amour
dramatique bien connue de tous roméo et
juliette de shakespeare elle a été
réinventée en 90 par le chorégraphe
angelin prejlocaj son adaptation est de
retour sur les planches depuis 2015 elle
est de passage à saint quentin en
yvelines ce week-end au théâtre national
reportage de marie pas naîtra et mélanie
poquet
[Musique]
ces célèbres note du compositeur
prokofiev résonne de théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ambiance
angoissante éclairage sombre roméo et
juliette ne sont plus à vérone mais dans
un régime totalitaire des pays de l'est
une des plus grandes libertés celle b
mais finalement pouvait être mise à mal
aussi par un régime pareil et créé
justement un drame d'amour entre deux
amoureux une adaptation de la pièce de
william shakespeare revisité avec le
dessinateur enki bilal ici ce ne sont
pas les familles rivales de roméo
juliette qui s'affrontent mais deux
classes sociales pour moi roméo et
juliette c'est là en l'occurrence est
plus une lutte des classes qu'une lutte
de deux familles qui seraient du même
niveau social je pensais que la mesure
de lutte des classes pouvait apporter au
niveau dramaturgique une tension
supplémentaire dans le monde ce drame
27 ans après sa création le roméo et
juliette d'angelin presse locale est
toujours réclamé par le public une
oeuvre ancrée dans une époque qui
continue de fasciner
je considère que ce qui réactualise une
oeuvre quand on dit elle n'a pas pris
une ride je pense plus que c'est les
danseurs d'aujourd'hui qui réactive
cette oeuvre qui lui qui font qu'ils lui
donnent une cure de jouvence
une création où l'atmosphère pesante
laisse parfois place à la célébration de
l'amour
[Musique]
vous venez de voir un extrait de
flonflons et mu est une création de la
compagnie o'navio un thème dur destiné
aux enfants mélanie vous êtes allé la
voir
oui alors flonflons et vous êtes une
petite bulle des lic délicate d'une
trentaine de minutes c'est à voir en
famille dès l'âge de 4 ans à l'origine
un album écrit par esb et à auteur et
illustratrice jeunesse franco polonaise
flonflons et nous aident ce sont de
doudou on les voit à l'écran et des
lapins et c'est surtout des enfants qui
subissent la décision des grands j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est pas parce
qu'on fait de l'art du théâtre jeune
public ne peut pas parler de sujets
graves et s'éteint c'est un livre qui en
parlent en tout cas c'est une histoire
qui parle d'eux
de ces sujets là de la guerre de
séparation 1 mais qui en parle au sein
de joie et espoir voilà c'est malgré un
sujet un peu difficile c'est pour moi
c'est un spectacle noir donc pas un
spectacle noir lancée même drôle un mois
que j'y suis allé les enfants riaient
beaucoup changé nous aide c'est avant
tout une histoire d'amitié voire un
petit peu plus regardées
[Musique]
alors pour découvrir l'histoire de
flonflons il nous est rendez vous à la
maison de quartier joseph kosma de
guyancourt ça se passe ce samedi 11
novembre à 15 heures le spectacle est
proposé par la ferme de bel ébat merci
mélanie comme toujours pour vos idées
sorties juniors on passe maintenant à
laeken à notre agenda avec encore
quelques dates à noter le festival
documentaire 50 ans débute le 15
novembre avec une soirée d'ouverture à
l'ugc skywest invités de cette soirée
vladimir cosma célèbre compositeur de
musique de film le programme complet
jusqu'au 19 novembre est à retrouver sur
le site internet du festival
les coureurs sont attendus pour un trail
solidaire à vélizy le 12 novembre en
soutien à l'association laurette fugain
qui lutte contre la leucémie
trois courses sont organisées dès 9
heures débutants et confirmés sont
invités l'inscription est obligatoire et
ça y est le secrétariat du père noël est
officiellement ouvert les enfants
peuvent déjà s'activer à réaliser de
beaux dessins ou lui écrire deux jolies
lettres les courriers doivent être
envoyées avant le 18 décembre afin
qu'ils puissent y répondre
le site choisir est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivis n'oubliez pas
que ce samedi 11 novembre est férié les
médiathèques du réseau de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines seront donc
fermés je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
n